and we're back at it I've logged in a
while sometimes if I don't vlog for a
little while
I forget how how long has it been since
our last vlog Matthew it's been at least
a few days as usual my place is a mess I
can't seem to keep things organized for
more than an hour after they're clean I
just bought the prissy and Poppleton
books pristine Poppleton they're your
favorite Instagram pics re well they're
my favorite Instagram pages but whatever
I like the dog likes he doesn't get a
choice
hi sweetheart thank you for bringing me
piggy puppet what do you do when you
want piggy puppet you know what to do he
has to sit good boy good sit here you go
wow we're zoomed in Maddie your bag
we're gonna pack up your bag and run a
go visit Matt and Ed okay they should
probably clean up our messes first boy
[Music]
good boy sit stop stop ah like how am I
supposed to catch you
be a fun thing run for a walk I block
him off with the suitcase
they'll be coming like this for the
smooth right Alexa play Mumford and Sons
songs by
[Music]
hello Pokemon and it's all look who you
ended up but that's okay you can do what
you want pack my iPad so I can reply to
some texts like you so many of you guys
have been sending your messages and then
you're getting upset that I'm not
responding there's almost 30,000
messages that I've been going through
and as I text you then more texts just
keep coming in so it's pretty much
impossible for me to read and respond to
all of these but I have been trying my
best so if you guys haven't got my
stickers yet I just need stickers calm
feel free to send me a message I've seen
stickers at gmail.com you're probably
sick of hearing it at this point but
it's something that I'm super excited
about I'm taking it to Matt's house
right now not the person we're gonna go
to the dog park because Maddie's been
really bored cuz I've just been watching
Netflix all day and he's like get me out
of here mates go for a ride I'm also
gonna be vlogging in the car for the
first time using the GoPro Hero 5 so
we're gonna see how that works out in
the car Matthew you ready to go see Matt
you ready to go see ed I can't see you
so I don't know if you're responding to
me oh I think we are I think we are
ready to go see huh ed said triple
Maddie ID with win good light to the
group
hello I am replying via my voice Matty
is in the backseat and he is really
excited to see you guys
you're replied to Eddie Jenna and Matt
says I am replying via my voice Matty is
in the backseat and he's really excited
to see you guys so everything is going
to be awesome and I brought a Lego set
so we can put that together and I would
probably like to go to Whole Foods
because I would like a blueberry your
lamonta and then you know we can just
log around I'm gonna go to the dog park
also because Maddie's not to the dog
park
right II descended yes okay
I'll second okay you sent it and look
Starbucks if you want it
he does apparently there's like a
Cavalier meet up here and Maddie is
there's like a Halloween Maddie is
running hi Maddie
you trying to be friends with everyone
and the way I want to be your friend
Janata King Charles Cavalier or a
lobster this is Maddie thinking he's a
cavalier Matt's like Luke please go no
you want pizza who are those uh Oh God
just drop my phone Maddie come here
honey we gotta go get pizza hey is this
me or is that I'm mom what's happening
oh that's the next day um Oh careful you
can't run up steps like that you've
gotta be careful you're a little dog I
think I told you that I took like a day
or two off actually a couple more days
Matt from vlogging why is he so crazy
hold on I have to control my baby boy
he's crazy you've got to stay calm he
just tried to scale the freaking couch
good sit me and Maddie you have been
watching Luke Cage on Netflix it's
really really good but it's like an hour
or something long maybe a little bit
less I feel like the show could have
been such an incredible half-hour show
like I find myself just drifting off
when they start yapping about stuff and
like a little too much dialogue could
have cut some of that out got to the
point good sit good sit go get it I
forgot what I was saying something about
Luke Cage I think that it could have
been a really good half-hour show it's
just too it's too long I get to the
point
oh I ordered some some lunch
where's my lunch I forgot I brought it
up here and didn't do anything I have
been attempting to install my psvr
since I got it like weeks ago and I have
not had a chance to do it I always like
to get the soup of the day cuz most of
the time it's tomato soup but sometimes
they throw a little curveball and it's
not and it's something that's not good
not sure what it is it smells good
I'll have that yes I will Wistia you
stand by PC somewhat of my video
yesterday I said wow your desk is really
messy and you're right it is I wish that
I could be a neat person I do try I
don't know I'm just not yeah you have
this he's like I don't want that I want
what you got oh well you got thrown
within that container
I want within that bad the real problem
here is I don't have enough outlets my
playstation feels like it's burning up
you can shut it off it goes real
[Music]
hello we're about to do some psvr action
oh we need to update the files so I
guess this is where we're gonna be at um
everything's still updating Maddie just
had a nighttime walk we're gonna watch
some more Luke Cage because I can't
function until this show is completed
play no come on
spoiler alert
hi Jen that's your box oh yes I know
wrapping like a fake party tonight
Matt's watching the Cubs game or
something I don't know we're going to
pick up a carpet do you guys remember
the carpet rug that we want in bottle
barn yeah because I called them Tomita
one really have they never called me
back I left the boys once and we weren't
really interested oh my god this carpet
dilemma let's go find out what's gonna
happen here's my keys should we talk
about this a carpet situation they work
early and I don't want to I don't want
to talk about it either before my
birthday so over two months ago oh my
god do you think they still have my rug
I bought I paid for the rot yeah I'm on
route but it's just in the month and a
half are to come in well let's see what
happens because you know I mean this is
like I record my turnout but it's on the
street it's on the street are you dumb
yes it's fine yeah Street yes I am it's
my ií'd um you could always put one of
the couches
no I'm gonna pretty so you anything
don't like this I think it's nice it's a
bigger ball their ball their great
waiting for a power keep out good
HD buttercup camp out well we got we
waitin to the boys getting or make them
get it out yo boys hey boy hey boy
[Music]
you must hit me right in the face
come on Eddie up up yes I know what
Maddie did last summer Oh what's up
Sookie thriving and we party and I need
to get some Halloween things I got a
spooky pumpkin that I'm gonna put a few
light in spooky cookies not spooky what
are you looking for the cookies where
you got the cut I already looked they
don't really going let's carry on my way
these are holiday cookies the holiday
Halloween this holiday is one here yet
we should go to the other bread section
to France fresh bread we're making
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches for
the party because Jen and I originally
were planning on being a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich together like it was
she'd be the peanut butter I'd be the
jelly but the costume had such bad
reviews that I'm like Jen we can't buy
this and then we decided let's get it
anyway and then when I went to get it be
all sold out we gotta go the classroom
story make sure
we got everywhere to find it no one's
gonna want this costume when they see it
in real life they're so bad
look how spooky this is how about six
o'clock sangria
I'm coming every day
apps on app on apps on apps you know
this log that we're currently watching
right now is over the course of like a
week I started filming this vlog on
Sunday I'd like to show you guys
something
so we're preparing for the Halloween
party I'd like to show you my spooky
setting are you ready for this no I'm
pretty sure you're gonna get so spooked
we'll start with this color a nice one
wait this is not what I wanted it's just
too too like are you hold on wait ready
time for spooks so that's wrong hat in
my thing and look at look at your nails
whoa a Ned said that it was the police
car okay but come in here come in here
busy doing my tasks we've got some green
behind the TV just a little bit of blue
here just for accents because I really
like to have like when it lights up like
neon stuff it's so dark how are you find
anyone at this new party I don't know oh
wait no one needs a snatch anymore I do
occasionally okay a lot of people do
actually so this is this is one thought
I think I might add some glean because
it does feel a little a little cop car I
guess it's finally safe to end this vlog
look at me vlogging in the back so
basically I kept vlogging and I felt
like the vlog just was I just was being
stung I'm trying to figure out a way
just to vlog differently because
everyone does the same thing and I'm
bored bored of the same old vlogs just
nothing just nothing new everyone's done
everything and I think about how long
I've done YouTube it's pretty crazy
because I've been doing YouTube for over
10 years
that's not my drink that was my drink
from yesterday I'm a slob what do you
guys think of new MacBooks we're gonna
have one so soon
[Music]
okay that's loud I'll see you guys later
I'm gonna begin by hey one of the
biggest differences here is the touch
bar so what's cool about the touch bar
is it will change with each application
that you open on your computer to hear
some of the different use cases so for
photos you can scroll through and you
can also edit and rotate and do all
kinds of different things that normally
I mean you would just do them it's